déjenme mostrarles un ejemplo de
posicionamiento con css y dz e index en
la naturaleza google maps probablemente
muchos de ustedes ya hayan usado google
maps o algún servicio de mapas en línea
para ayudarlos a encontrar lo que están
buscando y estas cosas son realmente
geniales podemos navegar por ahí y hacer
acercamientos o alejarnos y podemos
buscar cosas así que como estoy en
barcelona en este momento estoy buscando
la sagrada familia que es una basílica
hermosa
esto en realidad es html css javascript
pero dejen de mostrarles los zetas
índices que hay aquí todos los elementos
que vemos todos han sido posicionados
usando css para estar unos sobre otros y
están usando seta index en una forma muy
particular para asegurarse de que el
orden es exactamente correcto
así que dejen de usar mi consola de
chrome para mostrarles algunas cosas
este mini mapa que en la esquina tiene
posición absoluta botón 0 left 0 y 17
index de 1 así que esto se pondrá sobre
cualquier cosa que tengas eta index de 0
esta tarjeta flotante que aparece aquí y
que tiene todas estas opciones tiene
position picks y tiene un zeta index de
10 así que se muestra por encima de
muchas cosas
el botón de zoom tiene un set a index de
2 eso significa que quedará debajo de la
tarjeta flotante vamos a mover esto aquí
arriba y ver qué pasa
lo ve esta tarjeta flotante se muestra
por encima del botón de zoom porque
tiene un set a index de 4 y el zoom
tiene un zeta index de 2 como puedes ver
google maps se utiliza en gran cantidad
la propiedad position de css
iceta index con el fin de presentar el
mapa y los controles en la parte
superior también utiliza muchas otras
cosas de css y de javascript
pero es importante que ahora empieces a
entender cómo están construidos otros
sitios web que no se parecen en nada a
los que hemos estado mostrando hasta
ahora este es el poder de css